Das Podcast UFO mit Florian Wilbreck und Sebastian Titzler. Hallo und herzlich willkommen, schön, dass Sie da sind zu dieser fantastischen neuen Ausgabe von Das Podcast UFO. Das Podcast UFO. Es wird langsam besinnlich, man kommt zur Ruhe, man legt sich nieder. Ja, die Weihnachtszeit hat jetzt offensichtlich angefangen, denn du trägst Hoodie. Und das fällt mir dieses Jahr immer wieder sehr, sehr wohlwollend auf, weil du strahlst, ich glaube niemand, den ich kenne, strahlt das so sehr aus wie du, so eine Gemütlichkeit, man will dich knuddeln, man will dich und die Zeit knuddeln.
Ich sehe mich als Anker. Ich sehe viele prüfende Blicke gehen auf mich von Leuten, bevor sie das Haus verlassen und schauen, oh, was trägt Florentin und orientieren sich daran, was das hergibt. Ich bin aber ein recht kühler Mensch, also das heisst, ich ertrage Kühle sehr gut gut. Das heißt, Jacke ist noch nicht rausgeholt bei mir. Ich sehe bei dir schon, du trägst eine pinke Jacke mit Real Bad Bitch vorne drauf, das ist dein Style für dieses Jahr. Und ich finde, du trägst das gut. Und auch eine sehr dicke Down- und Winterjacke, muss man sagen, es ist eine sehr dicke Jacke. Aber ich bin, wobei ich jetzt auch nicht so eine Frostbeule bin, also ich kann auch gut mit Kälte klarkommen. Aber mein Problem ist immer, ich weiß nicht, was ich anziehen soll. Deswegen ist ja unser langjähriger Pitch, der immer noch auf Wiedervorlage liegt, haben wir nicht vergessen, ist ja die Wetter-App, wo man sich vorher den Kleiderschrank aussuchen kann. Du machst ein Foto von deinem Kleiderschrank. Oh ja, das wäre noch besser. Und die App sagt dir, was so der Bereich ist, wo du es anziehen kannst. Genau, die App sagt mir statt die Gradzahl, die mir nichts sagt. Niemandem sagt das was. Oder die Sonnen-Emoji, was mir nichts sagt. Niemandem sagt das was. Was soll das bedeuten? Was heißt Sonnenbrille-Emoji? Was heißt Sonnenbrille-Emoji? Es ist wenig Sonne, weil es eine Sonnenbrille ist. Ja. Heißt es, ich muss eine Sonnenbrille aufsetzen. Blind, ist es ein Blinder-Smiley, was heißt das? So, und deswegen sagt mir einfach, diese App zeigt mir keine, auch so gefühlte Temperatur versus Temperatur. Ehrlich, imaginäre, unendliche Temperatur, all diese Kategorien. Imaginäre Temperatur, da habe ich keine Lust drauf, auf diese ganzen blöden, auch Hektopascal, Luftdruck und Luftqualität. Liter pro Quadratmeter, 20 Liter pro Quadratmeter, ah, okay, also nass oder was. In Paris stand immer, die Luftqualität ist wie gestern sehr schlecht, stand da immer, wo ich mir auch dachte, erstmal cool, also geiler Pep-Talk für den Tag, hat man richtig Bock das Haus zu verlassen, was mir eh schon ein bisschen fremd ist. So und dann immer dieses ist wie gestern, ist so ein bisschen so eine komische, so eine Mittelfinger in Richtung gestrigen Tag. Ja, so ein Nachtreten, das muss nicht sein eigentlich. Ne, das muss nicht sein und vor allem ist es so ein da, wo du auch schon draußen warst übrigens, also das warst du gestern schon falsch gemacht. Aber finde ich einen guten Ansatz zu sagen im Vergleich zu gestern, weil wenn du jetzt plötzlich aufwachst und sagst 18 Grad, keine Ahnung, sondern so wie gestern plus zwei Grad, so wie gestern minus drei Grad. Du meinst, so wie gestern ist ein bisschen schlechter. Scheiße. Ja, genau. Sorgt natürlich dafür, dass man nicht jetzt Panik schiebt. Du hast eigentlich so einen Referenzrahmen, aber das Problem ist halt, wenn jemand sagen würde, das Wetter so wie gestern, ich hätte keine Ahnung, was das Wetter war. So vor Gericht, hat es geregnet oder Sonnenschein? Punkt, Punkt, Komma, Strich. Aber das ist ja eine gute Idee, weil an Tagen, wo du jemanden umgebracht hast, merkst du, das weiß ich aus einer Erfahrung, merkt man sich natürlich das Wetter. Ja. Weil man sich Details eher merkt in Stresssituationen, die unüblich sind. Das heißt, morden lieber an Tagen mit unspektakulärem Wetter, dass sich die Leute eher nicht merken, oder was sagst du gerade? Ich sage, sagt immer, ihr könnt euch nicht erinnern. Okay. Was jetzt nicht der beste Tipp ist, weil es sehr naheliegend ist. Aber und auch andererseits, wenn ihr Juristen seid, werdet es schutzig, wenn Leute sich sofort an den Wochentag und ans Wetter erinnern können. Man merkt sich Dinge nicht, das ist meine Aussage. Okay, wunderbar. Falls ihr euch mal gefragt wer wer da am Mikrofon palavert, ist es Stefan, es ist Entrepreneur und Content-Creator Stefan Titzer, schön, dass du da bist. Stefan Titzer ist hier, Flo und den Willnorek ist auch da. Vielen Dank fürs Erscheinen abermals. Aber genau, deswegen würde ich ja gerne eine Wetter-App, die mir sagt, was ich anziehen soll, based on meinen Kleiderschrank. Ich habe gelernt, ich habe ja jetzt die Serie Your Honor zu Ende geschaut, beendet. Was aber sehr lange gebraucht. Und da erklärt Brian Kranz in mehrstündiger, staubtrockener Ausführung die juristischen Grundlagen eines Gerichtsprozesses. Und der sagt, es ist immer gut, wenn man sozusagen, also du begehst den Mord am Tag, am 8. Juli, sagen wir mal, jetzt gehst du am 9. Juli, machst du ganz viele Sachen, die ganz speziell sind, ganz spezifisch.
Und dann, wenn dich die Polizei fragt, was haben sie denn am 8. Juli gemacht, dem Tag des Mordes, sagst du all die Dinge, die du am 9. Juli gemacht hast, dann geht die Polizei zum Donut-Bäcker und sagt, stimmt es, dass da die Cola umgefallen ist? Und dann sagt der Bäcker ja. Und dann war das am 8. Juli. Ja, kann schon sein. Kann schon sein, war so um den Dreh, Pi mal Daumen. Um den Dreh, genau. Man erinnert sich nicht an den exakten Zeitpunkt, aber man erinnert sich, ja, da war was, da war dieser Typ. Und ja, das stimmt, der ist auf den Tisch gestiegen und hat gesagt, Donut, wo sind die Löcher? Gib mir die Löcher, ich zahle eigentlich auch fürs Loch. Ich habe für die Nutella da drinnen bezahlt. Und der ist dann hinten in den Lagerraum gegangen und hat gesagt, die Löcher müssen hier irgendwo sein. Wo kommt der Teig hin, den ihr ausstecht? Und das war ein Riesenaufwand. Und wann war das? Ja, so am 8., 9., 10. so was. Wobei aber auch nicht zu spezifisch werden, weil dann merken sich Leute den Tag. Das ist ein bisschen konstruiert.
Das ist dann wie bei Ocean's Eleven oder ich glaube sogar, ja doch Eleven, wo sie doch dem Linus sagen, er soll lustig sein, dass er quasi sympathisch wirkt und man ihm vertraut, aber nicht zu lustig, als dass man sich ihn merken würde. Genau, und ich glaube, so ist es auch ein bisschen.
Also du kannst auf den Tisch steigen,
weiss ich schon nicht, ehrlich gesagt,
ob da nicht sofort der Blick Richtung Kalender geht,
damit sich die Leute merken, was da war. Und man schmeißt sich Hilfesun vor den Kalender, reißt ihn auf den Boden, tritt auf ihn rum und sagt, ich glaube nicht an Wochentage. Ich glaube nicht. Klage gegen Wochentage. Ja, ich suche nach den Löchern der Donuts und alle sagen, sie können nicht nach Löchern suchen, Löcher existieren nicht. Und dann sagen natürlich Leute irgendwann vielleicht, okay, diese existenzielle Diskussion, die wir gerade führen, vielleicht macht er ein Selfie oder schreibt ein Theaterstück auf Grundlage dieser Diskussion und die heißt am 8. Juli und dann ist es so ein Riesenpunkt. Vor allem nicht an großen Events teilnehmen, das erste, was man denken würde, ah ja, ich nehme dann schnell an einem irgendwie Papierflieger-Weitwurf-Festival teil. Das ist das Erste, auf das man denkt. Das wäre jetzt blöd.
Und dann kannst du aber das nicht sagen, weil da erinnern sich Leute, wann das war.
Da gibt es Organisatoren, da gibt es WhatsApp-Verläufe und deswegen macht das nicht.
Es gibt natürlich Kameras, wo man dann reinläuft, nichts ahnend.
Ab welchem Punkt leisten wir Beihilfe zum Mord, wenn wir Tipps geben, wie man am besten Mord hat?
Ich glaube, wir sind so weit weg mit unserer kriminellen Energie.
Also wenn man sich die große Skala vorstellt, stehen wir ganz links und sehen, wir sind nicht mehr am Beginn der Skala.
Dies fängt bei null an und wir stehen so noch quasi in den Startlöchern.
Wir sind bei Tätigkeit, wir sind noch nicht mehr bei Straftaten, wir sind noch so weit.
Wir sind bei Tätigkeit, wir sind bei falsch geparkt sind wir gerade.
Die erste Richtung, in die wir kommen könnten, Straftatentechnisch, wäre so aus Versehen in jemanden leicht reingefahren. Trotzdem umsichtig gewesen und es wäre auch nicht unsere Schuld, aber wir wären so, das könnte uns was passieren. Aber ich finde das sehr gut. Johanna ist eine fantastische Serie und ist auch eine Frage. Johanna ist natürlich eine fantastische Serie und sollte man vielleicht machen. Ich denke mir aber auch, gerade in der Hinsicht, in diesem amerikanischen System, wo es ja auch Lügendetektoren gibt, die sich dann fragen, waren sie da wirklich in diesem Donut Place? Und du sagst, ja, ich war in diesem Donut Place. Und dann sagt der Detektor, ja, er war in diesem Donut Place. Man muss halt nur hoffen, dass diese eine Frage nicht rankommt, wann waren sie in diesem Donut Place? Da Da muss man kurz sein Handy klingelt und man muss kurz weg. Gibt es denn Lügendetetoren-Tests auch im deutschen Rechtssystem? Nein, ich glaube, die sind generell nicht zugelassen, weil die unzuverlässig sind, weil die selber manchmal lügen, weil die parteiisch sind. Die sind immer für den Underdog. Wir können es uns nicht erklären vom Algorithmus her, aber die sind immer für den Underdog. Ich weiß nicht warum, aber die haben so einen eingebauten Schaltkreis, dass die immer sagen. So ein Sympathiescanner, so ein Protagonist-Scanner, die sind immer für den Protagonisten. Und du sagst, waren sie am achten und dann sagst du nein und der Lügendetektor zwinkert dir so zu und sagt, nicht gelogen. Und denkst du, okay, ja, finde ich eine gute Idee eigentlich. Das ist auch meine Idee Toy Story, aber nicht für Spielzeug, sondern für normale Haushaltsgegenstände und Dinge, so eine Parkuhr. War Sausage Party nicht so? Wie bitte? War eine Sausage Party nicht so? Da waren es Nahrungsmittel. Genau. Aber es ist auch nicht so weit weg, also so insane. Aber ich rede von einem erwachsenen Toy Story, also wo du wirklich den Drucker hast, die Parkuhr.
Mit erwachsenen Problemen. Mit erwachsenen Problemen, ja, wo du sagst, manchmal der Drucker ist der Bösewicht, die Parkticketautomat, Ticketautomat, sowas in der Richtung. Vor allem Ticketautomaten, also verschiedenste Ticketautomaten. Dann so Parkticketautomaten. Ja, wie gesagt. Dann vielleicht irgendwie in so einem Vergnügungsparkticketautomaten,
um da auf die Achterbahn zu kommen, sowas in der Richtung.
Das könnte ich mir richtig gut vorstellen, die dann gemeinsam Abenteuer erleben
oder die sozusagen einem Menschen helfen wollen, dem geht es ganz schlecht
und die sagen, nee, lass uns mal bitte dem helfen und der kriegt dann immer Sachen umsonst,
da liegt dann im Süßigkeitenautomat eine extra Beefy unten drin
oder da fallen dann gleich drei runter oder irgendwie sowas in der Rechnung. Ist doch scheißegal. Ist mir doch auch egal. Ist auch so wie Hollywood mittlerweile uns schasst und uns nicht mal mehr in Meetings einlädt für unsere Filme und Serienideen, ist es mir auch scheißegal. Nehmt die Ideen, wenn ihr wollt. Ich stelle so einen Hut auf, nehmt die Idee und werft da mal ein, zwei Millionen in den Hut,
wenn ihr wollt, aber der Rest ist mir egal.
Oder nehmt sie raus. Oder ja, nachdem
ich gucke einmal im Monat in den Hut und
nehmt ihr raus, was drin liegt. Ich habe schon lange nicht mit dem Hut
geguckt. Aber ich denke mir ganz ehrlich, ist doch für dich das,
daher war mein Scheiß, ist doch scheißegal,
war eher darauf bezogen, dass es Hollywood mittlerweile
scheißegal ist. Jetzt machen die wieder Kevin
allein zu Hause. Ohne, du sagst
Hollywood ist nicht kreativ genug, oder was? Das ist ein bisschen, nee, sorry. Oh, nee, nee, das will ich jetzt auch nicht. Oh Gott. Okay, okay. Don't quote me on this one. Okay, Karriereende. Connections verbrannt. Stefan Tietze ist verbrannt. Du bist in Hollywood gerade von der Liste gestrichen. Potenzielle Coraborators, German Coraboratorsators, German Aberators und du wirst einfach einmal rausgestrichen. Und wer ist der Nächste? Ja, du hast das von der Edding-Ink. Wer ist der Nächste? Etienne Gade. So, Etienne Gade, Riesenerfolg, nachdem Matthias Schwallküffer rübergeschossen wurde über den Atlantik. Ken hätte als nächstes zukommen können, aber nein. In so eine große Kanone, haben wir in so einem Helm aufgesetzt und dann wurde Matthias Schweighäfer rübergeschickt. Nee, ich glaube, da wagst du jetzt ein bisschen zu viel. Ich glaube nicht, dass Hollywood an dem Podcast hier inhaltlich interessiert ist. Noch nicht. Noch nicht. Ich glaube, das kommt. Ich glaube, wir brauchen noch ein paar mehr Ideen. Du meinst, die Website wird langfristig noch ein Erfolg sein? Unsere Website wird ein Erfolg sein, ja. Oh ja, die ist richtig gut geworden. Vielen, vielen Dank an alle Internetmäuschen und Ameisen, die da im Hintergrund die Bits und Bytes herantragen. Ja, Raphael, dass du das gemacht hast, kann man auch mal beim Namen nennen. Der hat das ganz toll gemacht. Vielen Dank an ihn, der uns die Website gebaut hat, auf die ihr fleißig geht. Schaut es euch an. Die ist kostenlos. Noch ist sie kostenlos, die Website. Schaut es euch an. Ihr könnt sie reinäugen, wie ihr wollt. Hochscrollen, runterscrollen, seitlich geht nicht. Aber es war eine Diskussion. Ich war dafür, ich war generell für alles ist möglich. Du wolltest sie horizontal aufbauen, dass man nicht runterscrollt, sondern nach rechts scrollt. Weil du hast gesagt, das Leben ist ein Panorama und du schaust nach links, rechts. Du hast gesagt, dem Menschen ist die Hoch- und Runterbewegung eher unnatürlich. Der Mensch guckt eher links und rechts, so ist der Hals aufgebaut. Ja, und auch dieses, du musst deutsche Nein sagen. Ja, genau. Weißt du, dieses No, But. Und das hat man ja eher quasi, wenn man nach links und rechts geht. Deswegen wollte ich eher so eine horizontale Website aufbauen. Richtig, aber Raffee meinte so, nee, das macht man so nicht. Ja, und du auch, du meintest auch so, das haben wir noch nicht so gemacht. Ich habe gesagt, schau auf das Mausrad, schau auf das Mausrad, ich habe dich hingewiesen, ich habe mit der Hand hingewiesen auf das Mausrad. Ja, und ich habe es dann gedreht um 90 Grad und du hast nichts mehr gesagt. Ich habe die Mindblow-Bewegung gemacht und bin aus dem Raum gegangen. Ja, und war es dann weg für einen Monat, aber gut. War eine Weile weg, ja. Sorry, ich habe mich nicht gemeldet, das tut mir leid. Ein paar haben dich dann so in Tibet gesehen, weiß ich aber nicht, was du da jetzt genau gemacht hast. Ich wurde gesichtet. Ja, in so einem Reddit-Post, wo jemand so einen Tempel fotografiert hat, war ich hinten im Hintergrund zu sehen. Ja. Und die Leute haben mir gesagt, ist er das oder ist er das nicht? Ich war es nicht. Ich finde gut, dass ich immer noch täglich Mails bekomme und Nachrichten und DMs. Oh, bist du das hier? haha, und es ist nach wie vor Typ mit Brille und Bart. Und dann denke ich mir, und dann kommen auch manchmal Nachrichten auf Instagram, was ein Foto-Social-Media-Plattform ist, wo es Fotos von mir gibt, wie ich aktuell aussehe. Und eure Referenzen sind nach wie vor 2014, finde ich okay. Und manchmal sind sie sogar nah an meinem 2014er Ich. Aber ich bitte euch, dass wir einmal kurz so ein Update machen. Ja, nee, absolut. Ich war ja streng gegen Olaf Scholz. Ich habe gebetet, dass er nicht Kanzler wird. Du hast Wahlplakate überklebt. Ich habe Wahlplakate überklebt, ich habe sie vandaliert, ich habe sie graffitisiert als eine Säule der Hip-Hop-Kultur, der ich mich am nahesten fühle. Street Art. Und allein deswegen, weil es ein Foto von Olaf Scholz gibt in den Jugendjahren,
wo er mir recht ähnlich sieht, und dieses Bild bekomme ich täglich. Haha, guck mal, Olaf Scholz, in Jung sieht es so aus wie du. Und ich dachte, wenn er Kanzler wird, dann wird er es überhand nehmen und ich werde leiden. Unter seiner Kanzlerschaft primär durch dieses Bild. Deswegen bin ich auf die Straße gegangen und habe versucht, das zu verhindern. Leider chancenlos. Leider chancenlos. Aber tatsächlich, ich weiß gar nicht, ob du das sagen kannst, zum Thema Stefan Tietze in der Öffentlichkeit, ich weiß nicht, ob du das, dass du das Angebot bekommen hast für diese grosse Impfkampagne, dass du das Impfmaskottchen bist, Stefan Spritze, dass du schön auf Plakaten in der ganzen Stadt, ich glaube, jetzt kann man es sagen, jetzt, wo der dir geplatzt ist. Als du es abgesagt hast, kann man es glaube ich sagen. Du überall schön als Spritze, mit der Nadel im Schritt, schön so einer Comic-Sprechblase, jetzt wird abgespritzt, die große Impfkampagne, Stefan Spritze. Aber du hast es abgelehnt. Kannst du noch mal sagen, warum? Ich habe es abgelehnt, weil ich daran nicht so glaube.
Also man muss mir mal beweise. Vulgär war es dir nicht zu sehr, oder was? Es war mir auch ein bisschen zu vulgär. Also ich habe es nicht verstanden, auch diese eine Idee, wo ich mich irgendwie mit so Lumpen irgendwo in so ein Bahnhofsviertel setzen sollte und dann die Spritze quasi so an den Arten legen sollte. Da habe ich dann auch so gedacht, das war eine Riesenkampagne, Riesenkampagne. Da habe ich, nee, ja, auch in mehreren so siebenstelligen Bereich, wo ich dann so dachte, nee, weiß ich nicht, also, und dann war mir das ein bisschen zu schwierig, dieses Bild, und das war mir zu schlüpfrig, auf vielen Binnen hätte ich auch, wäre ich shirtless gewesen, wo ich dachte, okay, ich mache jetzt Sport, aber nee, ich bin noch nicht so selbstbewusst, naja, also deswegen, da kam dann eins zum anderen und jetzt genau habe ich sehr viel Geld von der Gegenseite bekommen. Okay. Die No-Spritze-Kampagne. Ja. Und ja, also mal gucken, ob da jetzt die Mischung. Und da auch Topless-Kampagne oder warst du eher Bottomless? Das Gegenteil, die ist also Maxi, also mit Winterjacke und sehr viel angezogen. Dick eingemummelt ist diese Kampagne. Ja, schade. Ich würde gerne mal wirklich durch die Stadt laufen und dich häufiger sehen in Plakaten, in Plakatkampagnen, irgendwie als Model. Ich glaube, du hast als Model eine Zukunft, wirklich. Du bist ein adretter junger Mann, du hast aber auch so einen Allerweltsantlitz. Ich glaube, du kannst da was reißen. Hast du mal, also wirklich mal als Initialanfrage bei einer Modelagentur
einfach mal so, hey Leute,
mich gibt's, ich bin da.
Ich wollte nur mal Hallose.
Ich lasse mal dieses Bild hier, weiß ich, auf so einem Drucker aus,
aber auch nicht auf Fotopapier, sondern auf so
normalem, dünnen, mein ganz dünnes
Papier, was ich zu Hause habe, mit einem Schwarz-Weiss-Drucker auch.
Es ist offensichtlich
ein Gruppenfoto, wo dein
Teil rausgekroppt wurde und viel zu groß vergrößert wurde.
Viel zu groß vergrößert und Magenta fehlt.
Und dann habe ich das so untergeschoben und gesagt, ich bin hier, ich wollte nur mal sagen, dass ich da bin.
Ich weiß, dass ihr beschäftigt seid, ihr kriegt viele Anfragen, ihr habt viel zu tun, ihr habt schon gute Models.
Absolut, Riesenfan von Klaus Meisner und
Dietrich Hoven-Sieb,
aber ich bin da.
Und dann bin ich rausgegangen
und habe außerdem nicht mehr gehört,
aber ich glaube auch, weil ich mich verschrieben habe.
Bei der Adresse, das ist natürlich schwierig, aber
mach das mal, also das ist ja nicht irgendwie arrogant
oder eitel, einfach mal bei
einer Modelagentur vorsichtig zu werden.
Nee, das ist nicht arrogant, das ist ein Eitel, das ist beides. Ich glaube, ich bin heiß. Ich glaube, ich bin eine Sexbombe. Also ich wollte es nochmal ankündigen. Ich bin hier, ich habe Zeit. Und auch eine Freundin hat heute getwittert, so ein Artikel über diese TikTok-Boys. Die Aufzug-Boys. Genau, die Aufzug-Boys, die finde ich lustig. Und dann gab es einen Artikel in der Zeit, dass sie ihr Fuckboy-Image loswerden wollen. Und ich hatte kurz den Impuls, so aufzuzeigen und zu sagen, wenn irgendwer ein Fuckboy-Image abzugeben hat, ich bin hier. Also gib mir das doch einfach, weil ich hätte gern mehr davon. Es braucht immer zwei. Zum Image abgeben braucht es immer zwei. und du stellst dich zur Verfügung? Ja, ich bin ja auch der Meinung, dass die
Welt ist ausgeglichen.
Also es gibt von allem,
alles ist so in Balance.
Wir sind eine große Sinuskurve und es geht immer auf und
ab und da, wo
Fuckboy-Image abgegeben wird,
gibt es Leute, die Fuckboy-Image
zu receiven gedenken. Also du bist so ein bisschen die
Entertainment-Industrie-Voodoo-Puppe,
die einfach bereit ist, alles aufzunehmen,
alles auf sich aufzusaugen
und bietest dich an. Ich weiß nicht, wo du in der Liste stehst gerade. Es ist ja eine hart umkämpfte Fuckboy-Liste gerade, wo man, glaube ich, eingelistet wird bei Platz 10.011 oder so. Da müssen erst ganz viele abgearbeitet werden. Aber ist ja auch mittlerweile, viele wollen es ja auch loswerden. Viele wollen es loswerden. Ich behalte es noch eine Weile. Mir steht es gut, mir passt es gut. Ich komme damit gut zurecht. Es öffnet einem Türen, es verschließt einem Fenster, aber da muss man halt dann irgendwie gucken, wie man sein Leben darum organisiert. Machst du lieber Tür oder Fenster auf? Oh, Fenster, Fenster. Sehr, sehr gerne und ich habe mittlerweile auch eine neue Form des Aufräumens entwickelt.
Aus dem Fenster werfen. Nee, sondern aus dem Fenster geweht werden. Und ich habe jetzt mit. Aus Versehen, in Anführungszeichen. Ja, ich sage mal so, ich habe zu viele Messer. Ich benutze keine Messer und ich glaube, jeder Mensch, weil du kriegst ja, wenn du die Besteckbox kaufst, hast du ja von jedem Besteckart gleich viele. Was ja Wahnsinn ist, weil kein Besteck wird genauso oft benutzt wie alle anderen. So, aber wer ist jetzt der Mensch, der die Regeln macht? So, genau, guter Punkt. Und ich glaube, man kann viel über den Menschen auch sagen, wenn man weiß, welche Art von Besteck bleibt am Monatsende übrig. Wenn du abwäschst, dann musst du ja, also in dem Moment, in dem die erste Sorte zu Ende ist, musst du abwaschen. Kontrovers, kontrovers. Bitte? Lass mal, kleiner Löffel, großer Löffel, Messer, Gabel, kurz mal ranken. Wir ranken jetzt diese, gibt es andere Sachen? Top vier. Ich kenne nur die, Messer, über Kuchengarde sprechen wir nicht. Messer, Gabel, kleiner Löffel, großer Löffel, das sind die Big Four. So, und wir ranken jetzt. Auf vier ist für mich das Messer. Auf Platz vier ist für mich der kleine Löffel. Was? Wofür brauchst du im Haushalt den kleinen Löffel? Lecker Tee? Lecker Tee? Gewürze dosieren? Im Tee kommt bei mir der Beutel rein. Ich nutze den Beutel zum Umrühren. Da bin ich pragmatisch, da bin ich... Nee, aber du musst ja, du brauchst den Löffel, um den Beutel runterzudrücken. Anfänger. Kennst du nicht diese Bewegung? Gut, es ist ein Podcast, leider Gottes. Und ich hasse es, dass wir nach wie vor schon viele Innovationskraft eingesteckt haben mit diesem Podcast. Aber wir haben noch keine Bildebenen bekommen. Nee, null. Null, null, null. Wir hatten einmal so einen Gerichtszeichner, so einen Illustrator hier sitzen, der aber zu langsam war. Der konnte leider diese Bewegung nicht... Wir dachten, ihr macht doch wie ein Daumenkino, wir haben angeschrien. Irgendwann haben wir an ihm gerüttelt und gesagt, wie ein Daumenkino, aber er hat die ganze Zeit nur uns gemalt. Und das Daumenkino war dann sehr schlecht aufgewischt, sehr wenig Frames per Second, es war so ein Frame per hour, war wie wir langsam auf ihn zulaufen und anschreien. Nee hat nicht geklappt, das heißt, wir müssen wieder zurück auf die Sprachebene. Und Stefan hat gerade die klassische Teebeutel-Geste gemacht, die aus dem Handgelenk auf und ab bewegende Pinzer, Zwickerfinger. Oder dieses Okay-Zeichen, dieses Taucher-Okay.
Das Taucher, alles gut.
Das macht man quasi, hält dazwischen diesen T-Dings, Ende, Papier, Chip und dann geht's rein. Das T-Ticket, sagt man tatsächlich.
So, jetzt reicht's.
Ich hab ein T-Buch.
Nee, aber es reicht.
Ich hab ein T-Buch gelesen.
Zu viel Wissen über T.
Aber hier ist Schluss, das ist eine Intervention, du hast zu viel T-Wissen und Sophie, Elena und ich haben so einen kleinen Brief vorbereitet. Ja, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein, das ist ein,. Ich habe ein T-Buch gelesen. Aber hier ist Schluss, das ist eine Intervention. Du hast zu viel T-Wissen und Sophie, Elena und ich haben so einen kleinen Brief vorbereitet. Der ist aber sehr klein. Ja, so klein wie ein Etikett. Ja, so. Und auf Platz Nummer drei wäre dann bei mir tatsächlich die Gabel. Bei mir wäre es das Messer auf Platz drei. Ich bin kein Gabel-Fan. Ich bin auch kein Messer-Fan. Ganz ehrlich, Messer im Haushalt braucht man jetzt nicht so häufig. Also schon häufiger, auf jeden Fall ist es ein kleiner Löffel. Aber ich bin der, Moment, Gabel, hast du schon gesagt? Ja, Gabel auf drei. Wann kommt denn dein kleiner Löffel bei dir? Bist du bescheuert? Du lebst alles falsch. Wart mal ab, mein Lieber. Wart mal ab. Ich bin gelöffelt ohne Ende, ne? Mit dir zu Hause. Also ganz ehrlich, ja, Messer, ich bin auch ein großer Pasta-Fan, braucht man jetzt auch nicht unbedingt Messer. Alles, was jetzt noch gleich kommt, brauche ich auch eher kein Messer. Also ich mag diese ultrascharfen Supermesser, so diese Steakmesser und die Schneidemesser. Aber die sind gerade nicht in the mix. Genau, dieses klassische Besteckmesser, wofür braucht man das denn eigentlich? Wenn du Kartoffelbrei isst, das dann so raufzuschieben oder so? Wie Besuch. Nerviger Besuch kriegt dieser hölzernen Messer. Man könnte meinen, es wäre aus Holz. So, du hast Messer auf drei? Messer auf drei. Gut, dann kommen wir zu Platz zwei ist für mich der kleine Löffel. Praktischer Löffel zum Thema, ich rede von Milchreis, ich rede von Pudding, ich rede von... Milchreis ist so mit dem kleinen Löffel? Joghurel? Ja klar, den kleinen Becher. Ach so, das habe ich gar nicht. Ich habe auch keinen Joghurt. Nee, klar, viele Becher, ich rede von Wackelpudding im kleinen Becher, ich rede von Tee. Das klingt nach viel Plastik im Hause Will. Muss nicht sein, du kannst auch Wackelpudding selber machen und zum Beispiel auch mit Süssstoff. Dann hast du eine galärtartige geschmacklich unsouveräne Masse, die keine Kalorien hat, mit denen dein Körper nichts anfangen kann, wo der Körper einfach sagt, was soll das, das ist falsch. Das scheiden wir jetzt so wieder aus. Das wird genauso ausgeschrieben. Wir pumpen da drin um, wir tun so, als würden wir was tun, und dann scheiden wir es wieder aus. Gefällt mir nicht bei mir auf Platz, dann kommt bei mir, was habe ich noch nicht, Gabel. Oh, okay, ich glaube, dann einigen wir uns auf Platz eins, aber die Gabel bei dir auf Platz zwei. Ja, wahrscheinlich Gabel. Riesengabel-Fan? Ehrlich gesagt, es ist ein bisschen so, ich will gerade alles wahrgenommen werden, als ich bin, weil eigentlich bin ich ein Basic Motherfucker im Haushalt und natürlich ist auf Platz eins die Gabel. Machen wir uns nichts vor. So oft esse ich jetzt keinen Müsli oder irgendwelchen flüssigen Kram, den ich mit dem grossen Löffel esse.
Das ist auf das Protokoll, das heißt, du legst auf zwei den Esslöffel. Den Esslöffel auf Platz zwei, okay. Bei mir auf Platz eins der Esslöffel ist bei mir auch, das ist auch statistisch belegbar, ich kann dir die Zahlen zeigen, ist der die Art von Besteck, die immer als erstes zu Ende ist bei mir. Ich rede von Cornflakes, ich rede von leckeren Suppen, ich rede von so ziemlich allem, was man mit grossem Löffel essen kann. Maultaschen zum Beispiel esse ich gerne, Maultaschen esse ich gerne, aber da trenne ich die auch so mit dem Löffel ab. Die wird nicht geschnitten oder so, sondern da wird mit dem Schnittlöffel, das ist ja das Tolle an dem Löffel, ein Löffel ist ja ein halbes Messer, ein Löffel ist ein stumpfes Messer und du kannst ja damit auch so Sachen rausschälen und so. Deswegen überhaupt kein Problem. Kann man machen, ist halt dann ein bisschen schlechter. Als der Kaffee. Und jetzt erklären wir bitte nur mal bitte die Eins auf Gabel. Ja, mit Gabel kann man ja erstmal alles essen. Gabel ist ja auch ein Löffel. Keine Suppe, keine Flüssigkeiten, nichts. Richtig, Flüssigkeiten ist das einzige, aber ich esse auch nicht Flüssigkeiten. Wer bin ich denn? Wenn du jetzt anfängst, Flüssigkeiten zu essen, dann hast du für mich eh schon nichts verloren. Apfelmus, Apfelmus, Suppen, Breien, Müsse. Ehrlich gesagt, alles, was du an Flüssigkeiten essen kannst, wie Apfelmus und sowas, das kannst du auch mit einer Gabel essen. Nicht so geil, geb ich zu, aber eine Gabel, da kannst du ja erstmal alles mit aufpiksen. Ich bin Pikser. Es wird gepikst und du kannst auch geil abtrennen, also es erfüllt natürlich auch die Messeraufgaben. Besser finde ich sogar als ein fucking Löffel. Oh, nee, nee, nee. Da würde ich mich bereit erklären zu einer Challenge.
Schön Löffelschnitt gegen Gabelschnitt.
Nein.
Erstmal kannst du nämlich auch ...
Du brauchst die Krümmung.
Was?
Du brauchst die Krümmung, damit du sozusagen die ...
Also wie so eine Axt, dass die Schneidefläche erst klein ist,
damit du reindrücken kannst.
Was du vor allem jetzt massiv unterschätzt,
ist dieses Nervige mit dem Löffel unter das Essen kommen. Manchmal, wenn du auch noch ein bisschen Olivenöl oder sowas auf die Pasta machst, keine Ahnung, hast du unten nachher so ein Ravioli, unten am Teller kleben. Und dann kann man mit dem Löffel... Da hilft die Gabel gar nichts. Dann kann man dem... Natürlich! Nein, die schlüpft weg! Versuch mal eine ölige Ravioli aufzugabeln, vergiss... Du kannst nicht gabeln! Redest du mir reden vom Stechen oder reden wir vom Hebeln? Du kannst beides machen, beides ist besser als mit einem fucking Löffel. Flutsch dir weg, vergiss es. Der Löffel ist nervig. Vor allem eine Olive? Versuch du mal, eine Olive aufzuspießen, eine ölige Olive mit einer Gabel, vergiss es. Aber ohne Scheiß, ich glaube, du bist kein guter Gabler, du bist vielleicht ein guter Löffler. Das tut weh, Stefan, das tut weh. Aber ein Löffel brilliert ja auch erst im Zutun einer Gabel, weil beides zusammen harmoniert. Du kannst Dinge aufeinander schieben, das ist geil. Da ist auch ein Messer mit einer Gabel natürlich geil. Klassiker, aber gut. Wohingegen Messer und Löffel? Ungewöhnlich. Ungewöhnlich und ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen überflüssig. Okay, aber jetzt finde ich das schon mal gut, dass wir uns darauf einigen können, dass das Messer eher in der unteren Hälfte anzusiedeln ist. Und so ist es bei mir nämlich auch. Bei mir im Haushalt bleiben ständig Messer übrig. Und ich habe mich eines Tages hingesetzt und habe mir gesagt, was kann ich mit diesen Messern machen, was kann ich mit diesen Messern machen, dass sie auch ihr Gewicht tragen, also dass sie ihren Teil leisten in der Küche, weil bei mir macht jeder mit. Da gibt es nicht irgendwie die Raspel, die monatelang nicht benutzt wird. Nein, jeder leistet seinen Teil. Und deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, okay, die Gabel, weil ich habe ja dieses Problem, ich habe eine Wohnung, in der man Durchzug machen kann, also wo man auf der einen Wohnungsseite Fenster aufmachen kann und auf der anderen Seite der Wohnung aufmachen kann, sodass einmal der Wind durchgelassen wird, also als Schlupfloch sozusagen, als Abkürzung. Lass mich raten, wenn du wichtige Dokumente auf dem Tisch hast, die weggeweht werden könnten, nimmst du ein Messer und stichst es von oben durchs Dokument in den Tisch ein. Ganz so piratisch ist es dann doch nicht. Wenn ich wirklich wichtige Dokumente habe, die bei diesem Kanalmanöver nicht wegfliegen sollen, dann lege ich die Messer strategisch auf die Blätter. Und der interessante Negativeffekt davon ist, dass wenn mal was rausgeweht wird, was regelmässig vorkommt, sind das Dinge, die entbehrlich sind. Weil alles Wichtige trägt ja das Messer der Ehre, den Ritterschlag quasi des Messers, das Gewicht des Messers. Man könnte auch von einem Damokles-Messer sprechen. Ja, kann man auch, vor allem wenn du es halt nicht auf dir trägst. Und dann, da wird das Zittern, die Blätter fangen an zu zittern, wenn sie wissen, oh, jetzt wird das Fenster geöffnet und ich habe noch kein Messer auf mir. Frage, kling die raus. Wie oft hast du ein Messer als Briefbeschwerer, Dokumentenbeschwerer, ich stelle mir auch gerade vor, als wärst du ein sehr beschäftigter Mann mit einem Geschäftsmann, mit einem ganz vielen Dokumenten rumliegen in der Wohnung, die du dann so beschwerst, wie oft hast du einen Einsatz, bis es in die Spülmaschine kommt? Durchgängig. Kein Spülbedarf, nee. Du hast gerade gesagt, so großkotzig. Wer wäscht denn seine Briefbeschwerer? Hast du deinen Briefbeschwerer jemals hier mit deinem Grimmepreis und stellst du auch nochmal schön auf deine Bestellscheine? Natürlich nicht. Wie oft wäscht du deine Preise? Gar nicht. Aber jetzt mal, nee, weil ich dachte gerade, ah okay, spannend, bei dir bleiben
immer vor dem Spülgang
bleibt immer zu viel über
von einer Sorte. Und als du meintest,
bei mir spielt alles eine Rolle und alles wird
mitgenommen, alles hat seinen Platz in der Küche,
im Haushalt, dachte ich, ah okay, du schaffst es
irgendwie, die Messersolenbenutzung zu nehmen,
dass sie auch gespült werden müssen,
damit du halt diesen Gleichgewicht in der Besteckschublade,
weil bei mir geht es ja, das ist ja auch CD bei mir, ich will ja Gleichgewicht in der Besteckschublade haben, das kriegst du ja damit auch nicht hin.
Nee.
Wo kommen wir da hin?
Mein Problem ist natürlich auch, dass ich ein, ich hasse Sonderwünsche, ich bin, ich äussere nicht gerne Extrawünsche. Beispiel, ich bin in einer fremden Stadt, zum Beispiel in Berlin. In Berlin gibt es ein Restaurant, wo ich gerne esse, aber ich will nicht alleine in dem Restaurant sitzen. Das heißt, ich bestelle Takeaway. Wunderbar. Das ist aber jetzt Essen, dass man, da braucht man Besteck dafür. Und jetzt könnte man natürlich beim Takeaway sagen, hallo, kann ich dazu Besteck haben? Und dann kriegst du so einen Holzlöffel. Will ich aber nicht. Scheue ich mich dafür. Bin ich zur Feige. Und was ist die Konsequenz? Ist, dass ich mir Besteck kaufe. Ich gehe zu Karstadt und kaufe mir einen Löffel und ein Messer in der Regel. Ja, jetzt kontrovers, aber das wird durch das Gericht bedingt. Ja, aber dann kannst du an der Rezeption fragen, du kriegst einfach ein Messer. Ich mag keine Extrawünsche. Oh mein Gott. Als wir in Berlin aufgenommen haben, in meinem Hotelzimmer, wurde am Tag davor verzehrt, Takeaway-Essen, mit gekauftem Besteck. Das kann nicht dein Ernst sein. Und dann legst du diesen fremden Kacklöffel, legst du dann bei dir zu Hause deine Besteckschublade. Ja, sicher. Was rum, das ist so ein guter, der hat eine bessere Qualität als die Besteck, das ich sonst habe. Wenn du einzeln Besteck kaufst bei Kar so. Aber das ist doch was anderes, dann hast du ganz viele verschiedene Löffel bei dir in der Besteckschublade hängen. Ja. Vielleicht haben das, ich weiß nicht, ob das gerade Konto wäre. Ich weiß, du bist Purist, du bist Design, ja, ja, ja, ja, aber mir ist das egal. Ich habe gerne Besteck, mit dem ich Geschichten verbinde, wo ich weiß, ah ja, das habe ich dem geklaut, ah, das ist da liegen geblieben, das habe ich noch aus der alten WG mitgehen lassen und so. Da weiß ich noch, bei jedem Löffel kann ich eine Geschichte erzählen. Wenn es mal nicht gut läuft beim Abendessen, irgendwie Besuch ist da und man verfängt sich in politischen Diskussionen, kann ich immer sagen, du, der Löffel, mit dem du gerade isst, den habe ich aus dem Museum geklaut. Das war der letzte Löffel, von dem Willy Brandt gegessen hat. Ich habe im Weltkriegsmuseum geklaut.
Es war Hitlers Löffel.
Hitlers Helfer, Hitlers Löffel.
Ja, wie viele gibt es denn? Wie viele Hitlers Löffel gibt es denn? Hat die mal jemand zusammengetragen?
Ich weiß nicht, aber ich
gebe dir recht mit dem, also ich bin
jemand, der jetzt fragt an der Rezeption, in guten
Hotels frage ich super gern nach sowas,
weil ich immer denke, dafür habe ich jetzt bezahlt. In guten Hotels habe ich immer das Gefühl, habe ich schon alles in Anspruch genommen, wofür man am Anfang bezahlt hat. Da bin ich so ein bisschen so, ich bin immer ein bisschen genervt, wenn da, weil, keine Ahnung, ich will dann genau das alles in Anspruch nehmen, was man da an mehr Geld bezahlt hat. Und deswegen, weil sonst hätte man auch immer ein Motel One. Nicht sprich gegen ein Motel One. Außer, dass ich mich da nicht so gerne, weil da finde ich es okay, wenn die mir, wenn die Sonderwünsche ausschlagen, weil man hat nichts dafür getan. Nein, Herr Tietze, Sie kriegen jetzt nicht noch ein Kondom, Sie sind schon das dritte Mal da und Sie zwinkern mir immer so unangenehm zu, wenn ich Ihnen das reiche, Sie kriegen jetzt keine mehr. Bitte, gehen Sie noch ... Naja, aber du hast völlig recht mit Sonderwünschen, weil als ich jetzt in Paris war, und es ist ja die Stadt, wir kennen es alle spätestens seit Ratatouille, es ist die Stadt der Kulinarik. Da sind die weltbesten Restaurants, die waren alle so teuer, deswegen war ich auch in einem guten Restaurant. Aber einen Abend Abend mal habe ich gesagt, komm, wir müssen auch mal ein gutes Restaurant mitnehmen, man ist hier schließlich, man ist nicht so häufig in Paris.
Und dann war das so ein Restaurant, was dann so ein Konzept hatte, dass die Küche offen war. Es wurde quasi gekocht und man sass dann, die Tische waren quasi an der Küche direkt. Das heisst du an so einer Bar. Und man saß dann da und hat in die Küche geguckt. Und dann war da so ein sehr junger, mega cooler Koch, der immer was gesagt hat, auf Französisch immer durch die Küche gerufen hat und alle immer Oui Chef. Alle haben immer Oui Chef gesagt und haben das dann ausgeführt. So nach dem Motto, ja, ich habe bei mir jetzt die Information angekommen, wenn ich es jetzt verkacke, liegt es an mir. Fand ich total geil, diese krassen Hierarchien, pure Diktatur in der Küche, war super geil zuzugucken. Und dann hat man aber auch immer mitbekommen, man hat was bestellt und ich bin in so guten Restaurants auch immer, ich habe auch immer Angst vor so Experimenten und sowas und nehme dann auch oft einfach die Klassiker. Ja, Pommes und Pinocchi-Becher. So, und dann wird das dann, dann hat man dann das, der Kellner kam dann hinter einem, hat dann die Bestellung aufgegeben, lief dann so einen umständlichen Riesenweg in die Küche und hat dann die Bestellung aufgegeben. Und dann kam auf so einem kleinen, so ein Bong-Druckergerät, kam dann die Bestellung raus, der Chef nimmt das dann, steckt es irgendwo hin und gibt halt das an seine Männer weiter in der Küche. Ja. So, und das war ein bisschen nervig, also zu sehen, dass dann, oh, jetzt ist unsere Bestellung, ich habe ein bisschen gecringed, weil dann plötzlich die eigene Bestellung, die jetzt so ein bisschen basic war vielleicht, in der Küche gegeben wurde. Und da dachte ich auch so, boah, Gott sei Dank hat, also, dann hat man mal mitbekommen, dass Sonderwünsche, weil die haben eh schon sehr viel, sehr viel Stress. Küche ist purer Stress, zwar nur Rumrennerei, Rumschreierei, Leute laufen ineinander, ist natürlich auch gefährlich, man wird mit krassen Messern mitgehandhabt, mit krassen Temperaturen und so weiter und es ist alles ein irrelogistischer Aufwand. So, und dann kommt eine Bestellung mit, aber hier an Tisch drei, die möchten keinen Gluten haben. Und man denkt, als Chef denkt man, oh Jesus fucking Christ, nee, nee, nee. Und weißt du, ich meine, klar, in so einer Küche, wo dann auch niemand alle reingucken können, können die jetzt nicht in ein Essen spucken. Aber mit Sicherheit wird das gemacht in geschlossenen Küchen, weil wie nervig da Sonderwünsche ankamen in dieser Gruppe, war
insanely zu beobachten. Und hast du darauf geachtet,
wie der Chef reagiert, wenn er deine
Bestellung liest, ob da so ein Augenrollen-typisch
deutsch kommt, irgendwie Jägerschnitzel
oder was? Ich hätte gerne das Jägerschnitzel
mit Pommes.
Statt den Breitkartoffeln, aber Pommes, bitte.
Nee, ja, ich habe darauf geachtet,
kamen, war jetzt keine,
die mussten sich jetzt nicht verbiegen, vielleicht aber auch ganz gut, weil die haben viel zu tun gehabt. Meine Bestellung war so leicht kurz aufwärmbar und dann raus.
Das ist immer so diese Frage mit, was passiert dann, wenn da irgendwas runterfällt? Es gibt ja nochmal so ein Ohr-Schnitzel nochmal schnell auf dem Teller oder so, was ja wahrscheinlich natürlich passiert, aber mit einer offenen Küche haben die da extra Regeln, so Leute, ihr werdet beobachtet? Weil das sind immer so die Momente, zum Beispiel, ich habe das ab und zu beim Bäcker, dass ich dann so die Münze übergebe und dann treffe ich aber nicht ganz die Hand und es fällt direkt einfach schön auf die Zimtschnecke und mein Bazilleneuro... Und die Preise für die Zimtschnecke werden genau um einen Euro teurer direkt. Und mein Bazilleneuro liegt dann auf der Zimtschnecke drauf und die Person nimmt dann den Euro und dann gibt es diesen Moment des, wollen wir jetzt das Theater machen, dass ich die rausnehme und sobald du weg bist, lege ich die wieder in die Theke und ich sage, ja, ich bestehe auf dieses Ritual, ich bestehe auf diese Scharade und ich gucke dann intensiv stierend in die Augen und dann, oh ja, kommt natürlich weg, so. Und dann gehe ich weg und drehe mich nochmal schlagartig um. Und dann wird die dann selber verzerrt, ich weiß es nicht genau. Nervigste Mensch auf der ganzen Welt. Man hofft nur, jeder Dienstleister und Dienstleisterin hofft einfach nur, in Deutschland die nicht mehr wegzzulaufen. Wenn du dann so mit deinen stierenden kleinen Haifischaugen vor denen stehst und sagst, mein Bazilleneuro ist in euer Salamibrot gefallen. Still mit meinen noise-cancelingen Kopfhörern auf, ich verstehe kein Wort. Wenn Leute mit mir reden, verstehe kein Wort. Hör Podcast, ich aber Bälle befehle, viel zu laut, hier und da. nehm ich da raus! Verstehe nicht, was zurückkommt.
Ja, aber so läuft's.
Ich hab auch manchmal das Gefühl,
weil ich hab dann, auch wenn ich da zum Beispiel Sport mache oder so, immer werde ich
beschallt mit meinen Kopfhörern im Ohr.
So, und dann häufig kommt
man mal zu Situationen, wo man mal reden muss oder so was,
man will aber nicht jetzt groß erst Lied pausieren
oder Lautstärke von 99
auf 78 runtermachen, um
normal reden zu können oder keine Ahnung was,
oder will man ja nicht. Das heißt, manchmal
Aber Man will aber nicht jetzt groß erst Lied pausieren oder Lautstärke von 99 auf 78 runtermachen, um normal reden zu können oder keine Ahnung was. Oder will man ja nicht. Das heißt, manchmal rede ich einfach so, als ob ich... Und dann dachte ich nochmal, wenn ich das von außen betrachte, das war doch gerade kein Deutsch. Was war das denn, was ich da gerade gesagt habe? Ich habe nur ein paar Laute von mir gegeben, wahrscheinlich viel zu laut gesprochen auch. Das sind wahrscheinlich Dinge, die ich mal im Film gesagt habe.
Auch so im Zug, wenn jemand dann so,
wieder Verspätung, so, ja, das kann mal sein, so diese Laute.
Doof gesagt, halt wie ein Taubstummer
wahrscheinlich manchmal einfach,
also ganz doof. Ja, oder wie ein Tier.
Also die sagen ja auch nicht klare
Wörter, Miau, sondern
die sagen ja auch, Mä.
Halt, das ist eher so eine Stimmung, so, Mä. Undörter, Miau, sondern die sagen ja auch, meh. Halt es ist eher so eine Stimmung, so miau, miau, miau. Aber das ist auch gut, dass es vielleicht nicht so gut ist, artikuliert, weil wenn es zu gut artikuliert wird, dann kommt halt oft wieder eine Gegenfrage oder sowas. Und dann mitten im Gespräch dann noch das rauszunehmen und zu sagen, bitte was, zuzugeben, dass davor alles nur Blank, Bullshit war. Ja, und das Commitment zu machen, dass der andere weiss, jetzt muss ich mindestens 20 Minuten reden. Weil du willst nicht jemanden so lange nerven, bis er die Kopfhörer abnimmt und dann sofort das Gespräch beenden. Das heißt, du gibst dem die Möglichkeit, jetzt zu committen, aber ich habe gesehen, es gibt jetzt auch die nächste Generation Noise-Canceling-Kopfhörern, die zum Beispiel die Funktion haben, dass wenn du deine Hand von außen auf die Ohrmuschel legst, dann geht der Noise-Canceling-Effekt aus. Das heißt, du kannst dann mit den Leuten reden, dass wenn du deine, du presst quasi deine Kopfhörer noch doller auf deine Ohren und der Effekt ist, dass man die anderen besser hört. Genau. Aber es sieht eher aus wie, nein, lass mich in Ruhe, ich will dich nicht hören. Mit beiden Händen drückst du die Kopfhörer noch auf deine Ohrmuscheln, damit der Cancelling-Effekt ausgeht und dann kannst du besser hören.
Aber es müsste eher so von hinten quasi diese Elefantenohren machen. Genau, diese Elefantenohren hinter die Ohren, das müsste eher herauslösen, dass es dann aufhört. Es ist natürlich die Frage, wie lange es dauert, bis diese Geste in den allgemeinen Gebrauch übergeht und man versteht, aha, der legt die Hand auf meinen Kopfhörer, jetzt hört er mich besser. Weiß man noch nicht genau, bin mir nicht sicher. Aber das ist eh die coolste Bewegung. Auch so immer, wenn so Geheimagenten mit so einem Earpiece und dann so den Finger auf das Ohrstück legen. So, ja, er ist genannt Roger Over. Das ist der coolste Moment. Aber streng genommen schlechte Geheimagenten. Coolster Moment, aber schlechteste Geheimagenten. Absolut schlechte. Fassen sich nicht ans Ohr. Fassen sich niemals ans Ohr. Nicht ans Ohr fassen. Oder auch so Korrespondenten so, ich gebe zurück
ans Studio, auch immer mit der Hand am Ohr,
das ist eigentlich Korrespondenten,
Geheimagenten und DJs.
Eine Schnittmenge von diesen drei
Berufsgruppen ist das Finger ans Ohr
legen eigentlich und auch als DJ
irgendwie so. Toll. Als DJ auch
natürlich immer nur ein
Stöpsel im Ohr oder
Stöpsel nicht, wenn man diese großen Ohr tragen. Dahrs. Da musst du halt von einem Track zum nächsten Track den Übergang finden. Wann ist der richtige Zeitpunkt, musst du beide gleichzeitig hören. Ich hab bis heute nicht genau verstanden, was die Aufnahme ist. Ich auch nicht. Ich glaube, guter Geschmack ist eins, also guter Musikgeschmack. Ja, und Party und einfach Stimmung machen. Na ja, was ist deine Aufgabe? Don't drink and drive, wem gehört das Auto? Haha, BBF3, da steht in der Einfall, Leute, habt einen schönen Abend. So, das musst du als DJ einfach leisten können. Und ich sag mal so, hätte ich nicht solche Angst um mein Gehör, würde ich, glaube ich, mehr auch in Richtung DJ gehen. So ein VHS-Kurs. Du musst nicht laut hören, du bist der einzige in dem Laden, der es leise hören kann. Ja, aber du bist trotzdem ausgesetzt diesem lauten Party-Tümmel, das ist nicht meins. Und die Leute brüllen ja auch immer ins Ohr, dann kommt jemand an, ist betrunken und will irgendwie Popper anschauen. Habt ihr High School Musical? Habt ihr High School Musical? We all this together. Das heißt, der Song guckt, du hast ja gar nicht geguckt. Weißt du, alle Songs, die du hast? Nee, das will ich halt nicht so. Deswegen, mir ist mein Gehör sehr wichtig, weil es der letzte Sinn ist, den ich noch habe, um ganz ehrlich zu sein. Meine Nase verabschiedet sich, ich schmecke so gut wie nichts, meine Augen werden kleiner, jeden Tag schrumpeln in sich zusammen. Wie so Rosinen. Und Gehör ist das einzige Sinnesorgan, das ich noch habe, verlässlich. Und das möchte ich nicht verlieren. Und da achtet lieber jetzt mal drauf, liebe Podcast-Hörerinnen und Hörer, stellt gern mal euer Device zwei Stufen leiser ein. Geht auch. Ja, guckt mal. Ihr hört immer noch wunderbar genug, aber es kommt oft vor, dass man über den Tag hinweg immer lauter schaltet. Dann kommt wieder so ein Feuerwehrzug an einem vorbei. Man stellt das mal zwei hoch und dann stellt man es nicht mehr runter.
Also alle mal jetzt bei drei, zwei, eins, zwei runter. Zwei runter. Guckt mal, ich habe, also heute bin ich an so einer Strasse vorbei, wo dann links so ein Optiker war, wo geworben wurde für einen Sehtest, einen günstigen Sehtest oder kostenlos. Und dann war, die Werbung war dafür, dieser typische
Sehtest, den man kennt, mit diesen grossen
Buchstaben, die dann in jeder Zeile immer kleiner
werden. Warum habt ihr
den nicht unscharf gemacht?
Wenn dieses Bild unscharf wäre,
ihr hättet mehr Kunden. Ja, das stimmt.
Ihr würdet mehr Leute reinlaufen. Auch wenn das Schild
vom Optiker unscharf ist, warum denn
nicht? Ich dachte auch gerade, wenn wir Werbung
machen, mal irgendwann für Hörgeräte,
dann ist diese Werbung so leise.
Unhörbar leise.
Und dann ist die Werbung vorbei und wir
labern wieder lautlos.
Ja, finde ich eine gute Idee.
Aber vor allem, wenn du für den Sehtest wirbst,
aber dieses Schild in das Schaufenster stellst,
das ist ja schon der Sehtest, oder?
Ja. Also ich würde so machen, mach lieber eine Linie auf dem Gehsteig, farbig, lila, und dann hast du das Schild im Schaufenster und die Leute können sich auf die Linie stellen und gucken, wie viel sie schaffen. Dann machst du ja schon einen Sehtest. Ja genau, und dann schreibst du drüber, wenn sie es nicht bis Zeile vier geschafft haben, Brille. Aber in grossen Lettern, in riesigen Lettern, Brille. Auch als Tonspur läuft das. Wenn sie es nicht bis Zeile drei geschafft haben, Brille, und dann kriegst du so ein Ticket, wird rausgedrückt, so ein Ticket, das reißt du ab und da kriegst du dann auch noch zehn Prozent Rabatt auf die Brille, zack, kein Problem. Kein Problem, finde ich gut, finde ich super. Ich dachte die ganze Zeit, merkwürdig, dass in Brillenläden nur Brillenträger arbeiten, Brillenträgerinnen. Aber es wäre auch merkwürdig, wenn nicht, ehrlich gesagt, dachte ich auch. Kann man bei viel Mann eingestellt werden, wenn man keine Brille trägt? Ja, das stimmt schon. Ja, also sie haben absolut beste Qualifikationen, sie sind freundlich, sie haben Erfahrung, aber in der Dioptrienabteilung müssten wir noch ein bisschen gucken. Wie meinen Sie das? Naja, wir haben ja den Sehtest gemacht und Sie haben perfekte Sicht. Und? Also ich will ja nur arbeiten. Natürlich ist ein Vielmann, unser Produkt ist die Brille, da müssen Sie natürlich auch als Mitarbeiter voranschreiten. Ja, aber ich habe ja ein Gefühl dafür, was gut aussieht und kann Brillen empfehlen. Wir machen es jetzt mal so. Ich die Tests durchgehen. Ich mache mal den Vorhang auf, da draußen ist die Sonne. Ja. Ich gehe mal aus dem Raum. Zehn, zwanzig Sekunden dürften reichen und dann hole ich mir kurz einen Kaffee. Sie wollen jetzt nicht in die Sonne schauen, oder? Dann komme ich einfach wieder. Ich will meine Augen schlechter werden. Ich möchte von Ihnen gar nichts. Ich verlasse eben den Raum, hole mir einen Kaffee. Möchten Sie auch einen Kaffee? Ich würde gerne mitgehen und nicht der Sonne ausgeletzt werden. Sie bleiben hier, ich hole Ihnen einen Kaffee und was Sie in diesem Raum machen, ist ausserhalb meiner Kontrolle. Ich möchte Ihnen eine Frage stellen. Habe ich ernsthaft Chancen auf diesen Job? Wenn ich jetzt nicht acht Minuten in die Sonne gucke. Bis auf Ihre Dioptrien sind Sie perfekt geeignet für den Job. Fuck! Zehn bis zwanzig Sekunden sage ich einfach mal, dauert es, bis ich wieder da bin. Und dann möchte ich es jetzt kurz einlassen und dann hole ich ihn Kaffee mit Milch. Gut. Ah, wieder ein neuer. So muss das sein. So muss das sein. Und dann wirst du eingestellt. Vielleicht tragen die auch Fake-Bilden.
Vielleicht tragen die auch Fake-Bilden, wie ich das Gefühl habe,
dass Leute Friseure oft auch Fake-Haare tragen.
Klaut mal den Friseuren die Perücken und den Vielmann-MitarbeiterInnen,
klaut ihr mal bitte die Brillen.
Und dann lauft weg und schaut, ob sie gegen die Wand laufen oder nicht.
Schaut, ob die alle wild durch den Nürnnen laufen.
Das ist unser großer Scoop.
Unser großer Scoop, unser Spiegelartikel. Viel, vielmehr Mitarbeiter sind gar keine echten Brillenträger. Finde ich nicht schlecht. Auf der anderen Seite auch hier die Frage, wäre es so schlimm, wenn nicht, dass ja die Ausgangsfrage von der bekommen. Ich glaube nämlich, es wäre vielleicht okay, aber man vertraut den Leuten halt nicht, wenn die einem was empfehlen. Und du wirst ja auch wahrscheinlich, willst du kein Optiker werden, wenn du nicht seit Kindheitstagen damit zu tun hättest. Meinst du, wenn es deine Leidenschaft ist und du deine Augen verteufelst? Wenn es wirklich deine Leidenschaft ist, du verteufelst deine guten Augen. Das ist Augenkorrektur und sowas in der Richtung, aber leider kannst du auch Fake-Brille tragen. Also habe ich mir auch schon überlegt, einfach als modisches Statement eine Brille tragen. Ich musste ja für meinen Sportbootführerschein Binnen und See musste ich ja einen Hörtest machen, den man auch kontraktiv bei Vielmann machen konnte. Und dann habe ich jetzt erfahren, dass eine Freundin, die es mit mit diesem Sportbootführerschein gemacht hat, hat den bei ihrem Hausarzt gemacht und weil der keine Zeit hatte, hat er sich einfach in die andere Ecke des Raumes gestellt und leise geflüstert
und ich habe gesagt,
das glaube ich jetzt nicht,
was sind das für eine Information, warum sagst du mir das jetzt?
Weil, weil
ich meine, sie konnte und dann habe ich auch gefragt,
aber hat er sich wenigstens umgedreht, dass du nicht an den Lippen
ablesen konntest? Nein, er stand wirklich
mit Augen auf sie gerichtet,
einfach in der anderen Ecke des Raumes und hat gesagt,
Baum.
Und habe ich
gefragt, hat er denn einen Zettel mit Wörtern
Und Mit Augen auf sie gerichtet, einfach in der anderen Ecke des Raumes und hat gesagt, Baum. Und habe ich gefragt, hat er denn Zettel mit Wörtern, die man dann vorgelesen hat? Nein, er hat einfach Wörter, die ihm eingefallen sind, in der anderen Ecke des Raumes improvisiert. Und sie musste sie direkt wiederholen, oder was? Und sie musste sie sagen. Haus. Haus. Maus. Maus. Maus erfahre. Aber ich stelle mir vor, dass er halt auch kein kreativer Mensch ist, ein Arzt, steht in einem Raum und sagt Stuhl. Stuhl. Liege. Liege. Desinfektionsmittel. Desinfektionsmittel. Ich kann sehen, wo sie hinschauen. Skelett. Skelett. Ich sehe genau, wo sie hinschauen. Arzthelferin. Arzthelferin, hallo. Patient. Patient, ja. Ja, Sie können hören. Sie können hören.
Oder sehr gut Lippen lesen, was noch beeindruckender ist ehrlich gesagt und auf See gar nicht so schlecht ist.
Wenn die Gischt mal hochspritzt, wenn der Sturm das Schiff am Rumpfe packt, dann ist es mir doch lieber, wenn ich meine Matrosin habe, die meine Befehle ablesen kann von den Lippen, anstatt dass ich da durch den Orkan brüllen muss, wäre mir lieber. Aber das ist deine Sache. Wie oft warst du jetzt zur See? Ich war noch kein Mal zur See. Ich war noch kein Mal vor Anker zur See, war ich noch kein Mal. Rückblickend, wie sehr hat sich dann dein Segelschein gelost?? So, jetzt pass mal auf, mit deiner arroganten Frageart gerade, wo natürlich sehr viel suggestiver Scheiss mitschwingt. Ich glaube, da wird in Zukunft noch sehr viel möglich mit sein. Wirklich? Mit meinem Segelschein. Wenn ich den dann noch mache, den richtigen Segelschein. Ach, den hast du noch gar nicht. Halt, ich dachte, du hast den schon. Man braucht keinen Segelschein. Ich habe dir extra einen Kuchen geschenkt. Ja, vielen Dank nochmal rückblickend dafür. Du hast den noch nicht gar nicht richtig. Doch, ich habe Segeln und Mutterboot für Binnen und See. Der, mit dem man erstmal richtig segeln lernt, der ist sogar freiwillig. Ging dir zum anderen, der verpflichtend war, den musstest du machen. Ja, den muss ich machen, wenn ich Boote fahren will. Aber alles, was ich jetzt mache, wäre freiwillig. Aber ich kann auch kein fucking Segelboot fahren. Du hast auf halber Strecke aufgehört. Nein, ich müsste nur den S-Gas machen. Du hast, als es richtig schwierig und anspruchsvoll wurde, die Flint ins Korn geworfen und hat es keinen Bock mehr. Ich habe die verpflichtenden... Stefan, so war's! Nein, euer Ehren, ich habe die verpflichtenden Teile gemacht und jetzt muss ich mir nur aufraffen für die freiwilligen Sachen, bei denen ich aber actually lerne, wie man ein fucking Segelboot fährt. Das kann nicht so schwer sein. Segel hoch, Segel setzen, wie die Fachmänner sagen, und dann los geht das. Kann man zum Not auch selber reinpusten in den Segel oder ist das eher Cheaten dann? Das ist eher Cheaten. Oder man bewegt sich eher nach hinten, glaube ich, wenn man selber pustet, oder? Guck mal an, wie doll du pustest, aber allein nicht die Bewegung des Luftholens und so. Beim Luftholen musst du vorstellen, ziehst du ja die Luft von hinten weg. Ja, aber langsam, verstehe ich, verstehe ich, verstehe. Ja, verdammt. Also es gleicht sich aus. Am Ende bleibt man stehen. Ja, ja, so ist es halt. Und neue Hobbys, irgendwie jetzt Dart oder sowas? Nee, also ganz ehrlich, ich bin wieder ein bisschen rudere ich gerade zurück. Weg vom Segeln. Weg vom Segeln, rudere ich zurück, denn die Schach-WM begann. Oh, wie sieht es denn aus? Hast du schon Fotos gemacht für dich auf dem Schachcover? Das war ja unser großes Ziel. Ja, ich wurde noch nicht angefragt, aber es ist auch noch nicht vorbei, die Chance. Ich bin ja noch jung und im Saft. Aber die Schach-WM ging los, Jan Nepomnaci, der Herausforderer, trifft auf den großen Magnus Carlsen. Und wir können noch nicht, also das geht jetzt weiter, das heißt, ich weiß nicht, wenn ihr diese Folge hört, es sind wahrscheinlich schon ein paar mehr Matches passiert, insgesamt werden die 14 Mal gegeneinander spielen, also 14 Partien, und wenn dann noch unentschieden ist, geht's in den Tiebreak. Aber erst mal wird es 14 Mal spielende gegeneinander. Und es ist spannend, also es ist total cool und ich gucke das wahnsinnig gerne. Ich habe jetzt wirklich bislang alle Partien verfolgt, komplett, und die gehen in teilweise so fünf Stunden. Und ich habe wirklich jede Partie komplett geschaut. Also ich bin nach wie vor im Fieber und habe Bock. Ich spiele, muss man aber dazu sagen, so schlecht Schach wie noch nie zuvor. Also irgendwie ist da gerade so, da habe ich ein Formtief, ein extremes. Und ich habe auch überall meinen Namen geändert, damit mich niemand mehr finden kann. Weil was mich in meine Schachfrust gepackt hat, war halt, dass mir Leute, ich hätte plötzlich mal Beobachter, also Zuschauer in Spielen, in meinen Partien. Oh ja, das kenne ich ja. Bei den Plattformen. Das klingt ab, ja. Und das war nervig, weil Leute meinen Namen kannten und geguckt haben, wann ich spiele. Und wie heisst du jetzt? Jetzt möchte ich nicht sagen, wie ich heisse. Das war ein guter Test. Aber du hast einen Gacking-Namen oder eine Anspielung irgendwie? Ich sage das so nichts. Ich möchte nicht, dass er herausgefunden werden kann, sonst muss ich wieder ändern. Das ist ein Chesswort, ist ein Schachwortspiel. Das ist ein bisschen schachlich, ja. Okay. Aber das ist jetzt der große, damit geht man jetzt ein bisschen unter da, weil alles auf deutschen Schach-Wortspielen beruht da. Okay, möge die Schach-Diesign so was. Es reicht. Okay. Das wäre doch geschafft. Jetzt ist es mal. Okay. Nee, schaut einfach mal rum. Schaut vor allem mal die Schachwärme, macht richtig Spaß, wird toll kommentiert auf Deutsch. Ich gucke es gerne auf Englisch gerade, fantastische Kommentatoren-Trio. Und das Geile ist, die machen es mittlerweile wirklich wie so eine E-Sport-Veranstaltung. Es wird also wahnsinnig geil, reißerisch, schnell, wirklich nicht wie Schach kommentiert. Es wird richtig emotional und emotional. Ja, das ist halt immer so das Ding, dass bei solchen Sportarten oft nicht die Ren Emotionen dabei sind irgendwie. Jetzt war auch gerade ein großes Warcraft-Turnier, wo auch der Gewinner, Happy heißt der, ein super... War der ein Happy? Ja, nee, Null. Der ist ein Russe, super kühler Typ, absolut unemotional und der hat alle fertig gemacht, hat alle drei Null gewonnen und am Ende großes Feuerwerk, er hat gewonnen und er geht kurz zu dieser Trophäe, hebt die kurz hoch, stellt sie wieder hin und geht dann straight auf den Interviewer zu, um sich für das Postgame-Interview zu melden. Also einfach so null Emotion. Ich werde ja oft gefragt, hat E-Sports denn die Chance zum neuen grossen kulturellen Man wendet sich doch oft an dich. Man wendet sich auch zum grossen kulturellen Ereis wird und kann es so gross werden wie Fußball. Und was sagst du dann? Und ich sag immer, muss ich auch dann also ich sag dann, ja gut ich bin vielleicht nicht der richtige Ansprechpartner, aber Sportarten sind auch nur so gross wie ihre ja und dann fehlt mir immer das richtige Wort wie ihre Teilnehmer, also wie ihre Stars. So und leider Gottes macht man ja beim E-Sport manchmal die Erfahrung, dass die großen Stars haben nicht so viel Skandalpotential, Charisma und sowas und das hast du natürlich beim Fußball. Ich weiß nicht, ob es an dieser assigen Sportart liegt, die es da im Kern ist, aber du hast natürlich da so ein Starpotential. Man muss natürlich auch nochmal unterscheiden zwischen Teamsportarten und Einzelsportarten, sowohl bei E-Sport als auch im echten Sport. Einzelsportarten bei E-Sport sind oft sehr kühl und dann hat halt einer gewonnen. Aber bei Teamsportarten, wenn man sich gegenseitig motiviert und als Team, man ist dabei, um ein Kämpft zu sein. Und dann gibt es auch Skandale im Team. Dann gibt es Skandale und das ist dann was anderes. Da sind die Emotionen eher gross, aber bei so Einzelsportarten kann es manchmal sein, dass da halt einfach einer ist, der keine Emotionen hat.
Und dann ist er aber Weltmeister für neunzehn Jahre und man denkt, I don't give a fuck für diese Sportarten. Jetzt hat man mit Magnus Carlsen natürlich einen sehr, sehr, sehr, sehr coolen, der auch sehr viel macht für die, erstmal auch so ein mega geiler progressiver Norweger, der auch dann so mega technikaffin ist und irgendwie da seine ganzen Apps aufgebaut hat und Chester die vorher mit auch an den Start gebracht hat. Und er hat diese Play Magnus-Gruppe gegründet, die mittlerweile auch an der Börse ist und hat so geile, auch in der Pandemie, so richtig geile Events organisiert und so. Also da ist jemand da, der hat Star-Potenzial, der ist Charisma, der ist lustig, der ist bei Twitch, man guckt ihm gerne zu, ist ein hilarious Charakter, da macht's Spaß. Aber wenn du jetzt Happy hast, der alles andere als happy ist und keinen Bock hat auf Interviews und eigentlich am liebsten weiterhin in seinem Keller sitzen wollen würde, um da zu spielen, der will nicht auch üben gezerrt werden. Der ist auch so lustig, weil der auch immer alle Fragen direkt auf das Spielgeschehen bezieht. Ja, wie fühlst du dich jetzt? Ja, also er hat versucht, mit seinem Fass hier Druck zu machen, aber ich hatte relativ früh mein Graveyard gebaut und konnte mit den Fiends abwehren und es hat gut funktioniert. Okay, und also wie hast du dich dann gefühlt? Das erste Spiel war recht knapp. Naja, also ich habe eigentlich schon erwartet, was er gemacht hat und das hat dann auch so genau so funktioniert, wie ich es mir gedacht habe und dann konnte ich gewinnen. Okay, danke. Also wir gegen Null Entertainment, aber ich glaube, da müsste man die Leute auch coachen. Das gehört zu einem Sportler auch dazu, dass du auch so ein, heb mal die Hand hoch und Lippenbewegung. Wir lernen mal Emotionen. Wir lernen mal Emotionen, wirklich. Du freust dich mal, vielleicht einen Sprung. Man muss auch sagen, du hast eine Verantwortung. Auch als der Beste in der Sportart hast du die Verantwortung, diese Sportart geil zu machen. Ich glaube, einer der Tiefpunkte der E-Sport-Szene war, dass ja, in dem Gangnam-Style richtig groß war. Ja, oh Gott. Und zwar, wo anscheinend die Veranstalter sich des Turniers gedacht haben, da kommt keine Emotion auf, selbst wenn die gewinnen das große Turnier, die freuen sich nicht. Lass uns doch mal so machen, dass die Gewinner Gangnam Style tanzen müssen. Und dann hat die Starcraft zwei Turnier Stefano gewonnen, der dann, wo dann der gewonnen hat auf die große Bühne, da wurde Gangnam Style angemacht und er musste tanzen und das war so traurig anzusehen, weil der so offensichtlich da reingezwungen wurde und der war gerade an einem der Höhepunkte seiner Karriere gewinnt, dieses riesige Turnier. Man will fast nicht gewinnen. Und er musste dann halt so awkward Gangnam Style tanzen und war sofort gedemütigt. Stefano. Stefano, ja. Sofort gedemütigt einfach in dem Moment. Gott. Haben Leute da nachweislich extra verloren?
Kann gut sein, wenn man sich die Spiele anschaut.
Stefano war nicht der Beste.
Er war nicht schlecht, aber er hat da wirklich gegen Hochkaräte verloren, die leider Disconnects hatten.
Disconnects.
Und ihre eigenen Einheiten irgendwie verloren haben. Merkwürdig. Also es kann schon sein.
Auch erst nachdem bekannt wurde, dass der Gewinner den Gangnam Style und Every Breath You Take Karaoke singen musste.
Wie sehr willst du wirklich gewinnen, ist die Frage. Da kannst du mal deinen Ehrgeiz überprüfen. Willst du wirklich gewinnen? Dann hängst du dich auch rein.
Ja, spannend. Schwierige Sache. Also es ist eine sehr, sehr enge Zielgruppe, aber wenn ihr der die Beste in einer gewissen Sportart seid, dann lernt Emotionen und freut euch mal und seid euch gewahr, dass viele Leute zugucken und ihr die Sportart ein bisschen am Leben halten müsst. Schaut euch mal so alte Boris-Becker-Tapes an und zur Not einfach eine 1-zu-1-Imitation und einfach mal irgendwie ein Signature-Move, ein Salto, hier Miro Klose, der gute Klose mit seinem Salto-Mensch, den habe ich mir immer gerne angeguckt. Ja, da war ich immer gerne dabei. Mach das doch mal. Mach nicht irgendwelche Fortnite-Tänze nach. Ja, von mir aus, aber auch so lange in der Bewegung drin ist, mach von mir aus auch einen Fortnite-Tanz, ist von mir aus. Mach du mal einen Fortnite-Tanz. Viel Arm, wenig Rest. Ja. Oh, ich habe Seitenstechen. Scheiße. Arm hoch, macht die Arm hoch. Das war zu viel. Arm hoch für Seitenstechen, wirklich. Ja, ich denke, wir haben richtig, ja, okay, erstreckt die Arme emotionslos in die Höhe. Ich ergebe mich. Einfach Seitenstechen. Aber ich hatte lange keine Seitenstechen mehr, weil ich mich lange nicht mehr bewegt habe. Wann hast du das letzte Mal so laut geschrien, wie du kannst? So richtig so aus voller Kehle. So wirklich so. Heute Morgen war die Dusche so kalt. So kalt? Du hast wirklich aus vollem Halse. Ich habe heute Morgen aus vollem Halse geschrien. So laut du kannst. Weil die Dusche so kalt war, das habe ich nicht erwartet. Und ich dachte, ah, okay, jetzt kommen die Nachbarn rüber, um zu fragen, ob es mir gut geht. Das war so ein Schrei, da klang auch so ungesund, so, der ist hingefallen oder sowas, von der Treppe gefallen. Das klang so, als wäre mir was passiert im Haushalt. Und das ist ja schon auch, muss man sagen, mit die Hauptunfallursache und Todesursache, peinliche Dinge im Haushalt. Ja, ausrutschen und Kopf auf Klo. Ja, und so habe ich geschrien und es kam niemand. Wo ich dachte, gut, ich bin jetzt hier, ich kämpfe für mich allein. Ja. Ich kämpfe den Rest des Lebens in dieser Wohnung für mich allein. Und gut, deswegen kam niemand vorbei. Aber das da habe ich heute Morgen richtig doll aus voller Kehle geschrien. Du?
So richtig voll. Ich kann mich nicht erinnern, ehrlich gesagt. Ich weiß noch, dass ich mal als Kind in einem Museum war, wo es so eine Box gab, da konnte man rein und da wurden die Dezibel gemessen in der Box. Das heißt, du konntest da so laut schreien, wie du willst und die Challenge war, so laut zu schreien, wie es ging. Das hat richtig Spaß gemacht. Und konntest du laut schreien? Nein, nein, Nee, da war dann der Vergleich, ja, du bist immer noch leiser als ein startendes Flugzeug.
Wo ich gesagt habe, in einem Jahr komme ich zurück.
Wie habt ihr das hier reinbekommen, wäre meine Frage gewesen.
Darauf wusste
der Museumsleiter dann auch keine Antwort.
Und dann bin ich wegstolziert in den Souvenirshop
und habe mir ein Schlüsselanhänger gekauft.
Das war eine gute Zeit damals.
Das war eine gute Kindheit. Aber da habe ich mir gedacht,
nee, ich komme nächstes Jahr nochmal.
Und ich werde trainieren und ich werde meine Stimmbänder stärken und trainieren und ich will noch lauter sein nächstes Jahr. Und dann Cut, nächstes Jahr kamst du wieder rein, deine Eltern beide Augenringe, bis zu den Knien, so Augenringe. Jetzt mach's auch, Junge. Beide extrem abgenommen, extrem ungesund, blass, aber du strahlst mit so einem riesigen Hals, mit so einem wahnsinnig muskulösen Hals, äedrigen Hals, stellst dich da rein und dann ist der Kurzfilm vorbei. Ja, und man sieht dann plötzlich so die Ansicht von Deutschland und so ein Vibrieren über die ganze Welt einfach.
Und immer dieses Klischee, dass die in die Vögel wegfliegen.
Kann ich auch nicht mehr ertragen.
Da mal kurz so die, da ist jetzt der, wir schicken immer den Gag-Riegel jetzt hier vor. Zu häufig gesehen. Der, das Podcast-Ufo-Gag-Riegel. Nee, gesponsert von Snickers. Was mich wahnsinnig nervt ist immer, jemand schreit laut, dann cut irgendwo in eine totale, irgendwie establische Ansicht, Vögel fliegen weg oder sowas und dann schneidet man zurück. Kann ich nie mehr ertragen, will ich nicht mehr sehen, das ist vorbei. Der Gag ist auserzählt, haben wir zu oft gesehen, da lacht doch niemand mehr ernsthaft drüber im Kino, ganz im Ernst. Also du rollst die Augen? Ich roll mit den Augen und mit meinen Schuhen davon. Oder du lässt
die Augen gleich und machst einen Salto und du
rollst so mit deinem Körper um die Augen. Irgendwas dreht sich
bei mir. Weil du denkst, oh Augenrollen ist auch schon
so verbraucht als Geste. Du bist so
zwanghaft cool immer. Ich bin zwanghaft
originell. Oh, jetzt rollt der mit den Augen
und dann flippst du dich einmal
so um. Ich bin nicht einmal um. So macht man das
ja, ich bin zu too fucking original. Ja, wir hatten ja mal die verbotenen Liste, bei Gute Arbeit Originals gab es die Liste der verbotenen Gags. Ich weiß nicht, ob jemand ein Foto davon gemacht hat. Ich kann mich nur noch erinnern, dass einer der verbotenen Gags war, dass wenn jemand sich vorstellt und einen komplizierten Namen hat, der andere sagt Gesundheit. Das war verboten. Das Erste, was mir angefallen ist, der eine Gag ist dieses typische Sprecher-Gag, dass ein Sprecher sagt und dann doch das war ihm zu viel und der andere und dann sagt der Charakter doch das war mir zu viel. Ja, ja, den haben wir aber genauso eingebaut einmal. Ich glaube, bei einem Neomagazin-Sketch haben wir den mal genauso eingebaut. Ist auch lustig, aber halt in Maßen. In Maßen. In Maßen lustig. Das ist halt so das Ding, ja, in Maßen lustig.
Ja, genau, manche Sachen braucht man nicht mehr, habe ich dann schon so oft gesehen.
Haben wir diese Liste noch irgendwo, hat die jemand abfotografiert?
Ich habe die mit Sicherheit abfotografiert.
Schau mal, ob du die findest, das würde mich echt interessieren.
Viele Fotos von Wänden habe ich generell.
Ja, man muss oft Dinge fotografieren, weil meine Handykamera ist kaputt, es geht nur noch die Selfie-Kamera und dadurch mache ich sehr viele ungewollte Fotos, aber oft lösche ich die nicht, weil ich denke mir, in zehn Jahren sind vielleicht genau die Fotos interessant, wo man gar nicht fotografieren wollte, weil so mal wie die Wohnung aussieht.
Du nimmst dir ja nicht die Zeit und fotografierst mal deine komplette Wohnung ab, um in zehn Jahren zu sagen, ach geil, das war meine Wohnung, sondern das sind dann vielleicht eher die zufälligen Fotos, die man macht, wo man sagt, ah stimmt, so sah meine Küche damals aus.
Wenn du in zehn Jahren sagst, ach das war meine Wohnung, weird das sind dann vielleicht eher die zufälligen Fotos, die man macht, wo man sagt, ah stimmt, so sah meine Küche damals aus. Wenn du in zehn Jahren sagst, ach das war meine Wohnung, weird, weil du vergisst ja nicht deine Wohnung. Du vergisst vielleicht nicht, aber jetzt so wirklich genau, ach ja stimmt, das war der Schrank, also löscht man nicht alle zufälligen Fotos, manchmal sind das genau die, das sind die Schätze, die am wertvollsten sind. Ja, ich mache generell sehr viele Fotos von allen immer, du ja nicht, also weil, das ist mir auch aufgefallen, es gibt sehr wenige Fotos von mir, immer nach jedem Trip oder sowas haben alle so coole neue, tauschen ihre Profilbilder und so und ich krebs nach wie vor mit meinem Scheiß da rum, weil ich bin offensichtlich, wenn dann jemand, der die Fotos macht, ich bin niemand, der, man macht von mir keine Fotos. Nee. Ich bin, das ist irgendwie so eine Charaktereigenschaft, die ich noch nicht ergründet habe. Ja, weil du bist so als der Foto-Guy bekannt, deswegen denkt man, ah ja, der macht ja Fotos. Aber nicht von sich selber. So, du würdest nie ... So, wer fotografiert den Fotografen, das alte Problem. Wer frisiert den Friseur? Wer macht das Eis für den Eismann? So, das ist so die alte ... Wer putzt für eine Putzhilfe. Ja, genau. Das ist so die alte Problematik, die du auch hast. In allen Fällen, die du gerade angesprochen hast, ist es aber die selbst. Habt ein Herz für Fotografen und fotografiert gerne mal auch Fotografen. Ja, und ich habe ja auch nichts dagegen, wenn ich selber dabei auf dem Foto ein Foto mache. Ne, also nicht mal so weit würde ich ja gehen. Fotografiert Fotografen und macht nicht den Gag mit den wegfliegenden Vögeln. Das ist alles für die Woche. Das ist die Hausaufgabe für diese Woche. Mehr nicht, mehr nicht, mehr ja nicht frei, aber es ist überschaubar. Schaut gerne mal auch im Reddit rein, da kommen aber ganz viele coole Posts. Für die Fleissigen unter euch, das kann man auch so häufig, für die Fleissigen unter euch, könnt ihr doch mal die B machen. A und B. Schaut mal bei unserem Reddit rein, das Podcast UFO, da schon viele interessante Posts, ganz, ganz viele tolle Informationen, die ihr da findet, als Anschluss, als Add-on zur Folge. Und schaut mal unseren Club vorbei, ganz viele Leute haben sich schon angemeldet, sind Pufo-Club-Mitglieder. Ja, da kriegt ihr die Folgen komplett werbefrei, einen Tag früher und ihr kriegt 10% in unserem Merch-Shop Rabatt. Schaut mal auf Patreon vorbei, den UFO-Club da im Clubhaus Menschen, was wir da für ein Spaß haben. Wir haben so einen Spaß, das könnt ihr euch gar nicht vorstellen. Dartscheibe, Tischtennisplatte. Spaß, einfach sehr viel Spaß. Reiner Spaß. Aber wir schreiben das auch groß. So groß, dass man mit dem scharfen S an seine Grenze kommt. Aber auf der anderen Seite habe ich jetzt ein großes, schwarzes, scharfes S gesehen. Und das war eigentlich ganz geil. Wie, ein großes, das hast du mitgenommen? Ich habe ein großes, scharfes S gesehen. Ach so, eigentlich ganz geil. Wie, du, ein grosses, das wollte, hast du mitgenommen?
Ich habe ein grosses scharfes S gesehen.
Ach so, du meinst in Versalien, gross geschrieben.
Aber wozu braucht man das denn?
Wenn du gross Scheisse schreibst oder Spaß. Und wie sieht das aus?
Schreib's ins Reddit, da könnt ihr nachgucken, wie es aussieht.
Haut rein, haut rein, hat eine schöne Woche, wir heben ab, macht's gut, bis dann, tschau!